[Music]
dream it up dream something bigger than
I did that's what my grandpa always told
me when I was small grandpa was born in
the late 1920s when Vietnam was still a
French colony life was tough starvation
was a constant fear growing up all my
grandpa could dream of was survival my
father was born just a year before the
friends finally left Vietnam for the
first time
Vietnamese believed the peas and
independence could be possible but then
the American came and for 21 years of
the Vietnam War more than 3 million
Vietnamese were killed like grandpa my
father dreamed of survival but this time
he dreamed of something else as well he
dreamed a peace and then me I was born
when neither the French nor the American
were out food was scarce but I grew up
in peace and like many others of my
generation I could afford to dream
something else something bigger I
dreamed of a good education three
generations three very different dreams
to many people it is a generational gap
to me it is a dream gap for most of my
life I've been obsessed with asking
people what their dreams are and having
asked hundreds if not thousands of
people the exact same question I know
for a fact that your background reims
in fact your background can dictate your
dreams
in other words the time you're born the
place you go up in the family you come
from can determine what your dreams are
can determine where your starting point
in life is which explains why more than
20 million people today are still at
risk of starvation still dream up their
next meal every single day which
explains why millions of people in
countries such as Syria and Yemen still
dream a peace which also explains why
million of kids still dream of going to
school so many years have passed but at
different places in different
circumstances millions of these people
still have the same dreams as three
generations of my family had years ago
the dream gap but my talk today is less
about why the dream gap but what we can
do about it I'm going to share with you
a story about of a 14 year old boy
Kelvin who lives in a slum outside of
Nairobi whom I met when I was leaving in
Kenya Kelvin so nuts now the street
where I left he got me really curious
because I saw him so nuts I'd take care
of his younger siblings who were always
by his side and sometimes big books too
I always bought nuts from Kelvin but one
day I asked him the question what's your
dream
Kelvin dream I have none after wish
though I wish I had enough money to buy
food for my five younger brothers and
sisters he went on to tell me about his
family but his father had left him a few
years earlier his mother was sick and at
the age of fourteen he was the
breadwinner of his family
it's people like Kelvin that have taught
me again and again to be curious about
the dreams of people around me as
different as we seem to be I felt
connected to him because in many ways he
has the same dream as my grandfather did
survival growing up I heard the saying
you are as big as your dream and I hated
it in fact I was afraid the people would
judge me for the dream I had but knowing
that your background has so much to do
with your dreams I would never judge
Kelvin or anyone for that matter for how
big or how small his dreams are its
people like Kelvin that we might me of
their dream can that we come from
different places we have different
dreams and that's okay one day I asked
Kelvin after you thought of going to
college he said that is something I
really wanted to do you probably call it
a dream but I'm not sure if I can make
it or afford it so I tell him about me
about my dream and how I pursued it and
I told him that I would help him pursue
his dream too so every Sunday at 4 p.m.
I would help Kelvin sell nuts on the
streets of Nairobi 100 packs 5 cents
apiece
5 dollars was what he needed to feed his
family and to afford to go to school and
in between I would teach him math it's
favorite subject it's times like this
with Kelvin that make me realize that
knowing somebody's dream is good but
helping them with their dream and
helping them build an extreme is even
better and helping is an S
early about giving money but it's about
giving them support giving them a little
push the day I left Nairobi for Stanford
it was a Sunday
I told Kelvin it's my last day selling
nuts with you I'm leaving tomorrow he
was surprised why are you leaving I told
him remember my dream good education I'm
stupid suing it I'm pursuing my and you
got to pursue yours too you see the
stories of people like Calvin on my
grandfather or father I saw the stories
of dreams dictated by their background
but look around there are so many Kelvin
still out there in the world still
facing the dream gap I hope that with
this story you will reach out to the
kelvins around you you were curious
about their dreams and their lives and
the stories and that you will give them
a little support on their journey to
achieve their dreams it's my grandfather
that told me to dream it up which has
let me hear a Stanford where a quote of
the G building which says dedicated to
the things that have not yet happen and
the people who are about to dream it up
if there is a place like this for me
there must be a place like this for the
kelvins allow all of us to thank you
[Applause]
you